do you still care about the news there's
a report by Oxford University's Reuters
Institute which says that only 48
percent of people around the world are
very or extremely interested in the news
I actually think it is a good thing
if people were to be choosing to be less
focused on watching the news and more
focused on activism within their own
communities I'm not saying that's why we
know that streaming services and video
games and things outside and there's
lots of reasons and lots of things
people are doing other than watching the
news but there is actually a good
argument to be made that news hobbyism
people who follow news merely as a hobby
rather than to be informed are actually
accomplishing less than those who are
being activists in their communities so
that's an interesting thing